when I think of innovation I teach this
at singularity University an abundance
360 we focus on this and XPrize
innovation is when an individual has an
idea from reading a book or having in a
problematic experience and then takes
that idea and shares it with somebody
and that person builds and the idea and
shares it back and it's a going back and
forth it comes from that that building
of ideas rapidly and rapid
experimentation Burt Rutan taught me
something he said the day before
something is truly a breakthrough it's a
crazy idea and so I ask CEOs all time
where inside your company are you trying
crazy ideas and if you're not trying
crazy night a crazy idea is if you're
trying sort of incremental ideas you're
stuck in incrementalism you're never
been you know that you're never going to
expand and so innovation really is this
rapid experimentation of trying 100
ideas 99 are failing and one works and
then you build on that one you try over
and over again so you know the
traditional way of solving a problem a
grand challenge has been as a
philanthropist or as a company you grab
a chunk of money you grab an innovator
you give it to them and say fix this
problem very traditional but pretty
linear what we do at the XPrize is we
say here's a chunk of money I don't care
where you went to school what you are
done before your race creed or color or
man or woman doesn't matter if you solve
this problem you win and so what we do
in this sense is we're running a
hundreds of experiments in parallel and
so while the Ansari X PRIZE had 26 teams
from seven countries some of our
competitions have thousands of teams
that have registered and it's sort of
this Darwinian competition going on
where crazy ideas get a chance to see
the Sun sunlight and get experimented
with and you only pay the winner and so
it's really a wonderfully new and fresh
mechanism of innovation the concept that
we use the XPrize and I use a lot is
crowdsourcing
and its really being clear about what
your goal is you know if you don't have
a goal you'll miss it every time and so
if you're a brainstorming or you're
trying to innovate around what you know
you might say listen we want a million
dollars worth of revenue and we want it
to be very specifically in this area and
we want whatever it might be we want to
sell books want to do whatever you have
to define very clearly what you want to
achieve with a clear objective goal and
then if you're able to share that
objective clear goal with a thousand
people you'll get a hundred different
ideas and then you let them compete each
other out one of the difficulties and I
write about this in my last book bold is
that most people when they're trying to
solve a problem say you got all the
money you want all the time you want all
the resources you want and people are
lazy they'll use all the time all the
money all the resources and you'll get
very incremental progress if you really
want true innovation you want you know
something that's very different
you need to constrain the problem hyper
constrain the problem you say you don't
have a year and a million dollars you've
got a week and a thousand dollars fix
the problem and most people will say
can't be done but the people that accept
the challenge have to throw the old way
of doing it out the door and try crazy
ideas and occasionally the crazy idea
will work so when you're looking to
solve a big problem don't think out of
the box think in a very small box and
that's what XPrize is do they introduce
very significant constraints of here's
the amount of prize money the prize is
over in this amount of time and this is
a really difficult problem and it forces
people to come up with you know
non-traditional approaches because
that's what you want you don't want the
same old being used right you want
to be able to like actually get people
to trying new approaches and the
constraints is what forces people to let
go of what they're comfortable with and
try something that ultimately is crazy
and again like Burt Rutan taught me
David for something is truly a you know
a breakthrough it's a craze
the idea so let me mention something
else I have gotten most of my best ideas
from reading books books are for me a
conversation with the author it's a
chance to explore an idea I hear their
ideas and iterate on ideas in this
conversation for me for example the
spirit of st. Louis
Lindbergh's book on his journey was what
gave me the idea for the XPrize
Foundation Robert Heinlein's the man who
sold the moon was the book that gave me
the idea for planetary resources and
google lunar xprize
and the singularity is near by Ray
Kurzweil gave me the idea for starting
singularity University so one of my
greatest hopes is that Julian Guthrie's
book how to make a spaceship will be an
inspiration for entrepreneurs to go and
create their next great journey right
it's a it's a story of having a big
dream and hitting road block after road
block after road block and overcoming it
because it's your heart and your soul so
like to say to people is if you have a
kid in high school or in college it's a
great book to inspire them if you're an
entrepreneur read it to get inspiration
for yourself so proud that Richard
Branson wrote the foreword and and
Stephen Hawking wrote the afterword and
it's a book I hope will really inspire
you know thousands of moonshots out
there